near the border of long khanh and austin
provinces uh-1 helicopters flip into a
landing zone with units of the 173rd
Airborne Brigade to begin a Search and
Destroy mission against the VC it is
nine March and operations Silver City is
now underway this team gives first
priority to inflating its pneumatic
assault boat which it will use for river
crossings and recon the boats are eased
into the nearby stream as the troops
prepare to move out both the song base
and the strong dong nine rivers flow
through the area search during the
operation the action is taking place in
war zones II the Vietcong jungle
stronghold located some 50 kilometers
northeast of Saigon Operation Silver
City also involved elements of the 1st
Infantry Division and the Royal
Australian regiment as well as troops of
the 173rd the two-week allied sweeps
through the area with plan to hunt and
kill or capture the enemy in the
notorious zone deep which the Vietcong
had controlled with virtual impunity for
years
at another LZ in the area chinook
helicopters bring in more units of the
173rd 1/4 ton truck will provide
essential transportation within and
between forward command post meanwhile
other Chinooks arrived as pre-selected
positions with weapons and personnel of
105 millimeter howitzer battery the
howitzer crews lose no time in laying
their weapons and preparing for prior
missions in support of operations over
city in addition to artillery support
numerous airstrikes and bombing runs
were directed against the zone the
objective in another part of the forest
elements of the 1st Infantry Division
were filmed as they struggled against
some of the natural hazards of jungle
warfare this m48 tank crew uses machetes
and pioneer tools to clear a way through
the 6 vines and dense undergrowth that
had ensnared their vehicle the tank is
cut free and the column continues on its
way
it is now four days later 13 March and
the Allies are pressing Operation Silver
City into the heart of zombies but thus
far there has been little contact with
the enemies as the armored units proceed
they advanced by echelons who provide
flank security and avoid ambushes here
the demolished hood of a truck is
checked for booby traps about 25 metres
off the route of advance this unit of
the 1st Infantry Division came upon a
bombed-out VC base camp which seemingly
had included a sixth field kitchen or
hospital the camp appeared to have been
abandoned several weeks earlier a nearby
bunker is investigated and found the
service personnel sips - a few scattered
papers left behind and keep those that
might be of value to intelligence units
then the unit starts forward again but
soon halts when it comes to another VC
bunker
after a white phosphorus grenade is
tossed into the bunker it also is found
to be empty
another halt occurs when a DC grenade is
found lying in the roadway a demolition
man places a charge of TMT alongside the
guerrilla munition and destroys the
grenade the tanks in the advanced guard
recognizer the woods alongside the trail
by fire they form a column continued
during the day this unit made a five
kilometer sweep through the area without
contacting the enemy on the two
following days another unit of the 1st
Infantry Division was filmed as it's
conducted a sweep covering some 8
kilometers through the same general area
the sweep began at the unit's base camp
from 14 kilometers southeast of pork
beans and extended north eastward
through the song Bay River
a Hut discovered early in the March
yielded no Vietcong but several supply
items including an outboard motor that
had been abandoned by the VC from 5000
ball bearings and several hundred spare
parts for bicycles were also found the
outboard motor was prepared for
demolition
while the hut and other supplies in it
were put to the cross
some of the troops fill their canteens
at a small stream and then they forge
ahead through the jungle
later on the March the units emerge into
an area that had been founded by Allied
bombs during operations over city a rest
break is called while unit leaders
assess the damage to the area and check
the location on their map
then it is time to move out once more
late on the second day of the March a
smoke grenade is used to guide in a
helicopter for a medical evacuation
there has been no contact with the enemy
during the strange patrol but combat
operations under these conditions take
their toll in many ways including heat
exhaustion meanwhile other members of
the unit begin clearing resupply L Z's
as this small early phase of operation
Silver City comes to it's frustrating
clothes
at headquarters of the 1st Infantry
Division near Dion members of the big
red one fallen as their commander for
the past two years major general
Jonathan old seaman it's them farewell
at the change of commanders ceremony the
playing of the national anthem is
followed by an 11 gun salute general
seaman and the incoming commander
Brigadier General William Eadie few
troops the line the term only was held
on 15 March before composite platoon
from the division three brigades and
Support Command
a special message from the army chief of
staff citing the inspiring leadership of
general seaman and the ability of
general D fuel was read by General
William C Westmoreland Mac D commander
General defused previous assignment was
as general westmoreland chief of staff
for operation general seaman is taking
charge of field force of Vietnam to this
new command with headquarters at Benoit
will have control of all US ground
forces in the 3rd Corps area which
extends from 40 kilometers southwest of
Saigon to 150 kilometers northeast of
the capital
early in March a shipment of bolts of
material for clothing arrives in the
port of pag on for use by the Mac Vijay
for clothing production centers trucks
carry the heavy boxes of material to the
warehouse complex where it is checked in
and recorded it is next delivered to the
clothing production center the truck
goes to a warehouse for unloading this
is the Vietnamese whoremaster area and
is identified by the quartermaster
insignia appearing at the base of a
flagpole the shipment from the United
States is clearly marked as American a
the unloading begin utilizing modern
material handling method
one box is opened for inspection by the
Vietnamese officer in charge and the
American advisor the cunning shop also
employs modern methods of mass
production the many layers of material
are stenciled on top to form guidelines
for the cover
numerous pieces are cut simultaneously
as the electric knife slices smoothly
through the many sicknesses of material
the identification number on top of each
speck will tell the workers who handle
it later exactly where it is designed to
go
in another building liens of sawing
machine operators Fitch the pieces
together to form recognizable uniform
the trousers and shirt take shape while
moving through these machines field
uniforms are the most used garment in
the Vietnamese War and the demand grows
with the increase of truth
an inspector checks out each piece
before stamping his approval on it
in the finished product storage room the
bundles of clothing are placed in a
baling press to be prepared for shipment
a hand operated ratchet lever compresses
the clothing three such Baylor's can
pack more than six thousand uniforms a
day this is one of a hundred and fifty
items of clothing manufactured here
current production that the clothing
perfection center is approximately
100,000 uniformed and 150,000
miscellaneous items of clothing and
equipment for a month the cost of labour
runs about 10 cents a uniform for
cutting and assembly over 1,500
civilians are employed in the past
here are 24 different uniforms for
Vietnamese men and women in the Armed
Forces
both summer and winter issue are
represented here in uniforms
manufactured by the clothing production
center in Saigon
crushed rock for roadways and
construction projects in the camera on
Bay Area is mass-produced at this nearby
quarry a tractor mounted drill is used
for the first step in the process with
this apparatus engineers can bore holes
20 feet into the solid rock hillside
they will then place explosive charges
in the holes and blast large boulders
from the quarry while its work is
progressing other members of the
engineer unit use a bulldozer and a
crane to clean up the product from an
earlier black the crushed rock is loaded
aboard waiting truck for delivery after
the initial demolition smaller explosive
charges are placed on the resultant
individual Boulder heavy mud is stamped
around the six of em to dynamite to
equalize the explosion and to direct
their force downward into the large rock
next the engineers pay out detonating
cord from a reel and interconnect the
mudpack charges so that all of them can
be touched off simultaneously from one
blasting device the det cord which has
an extremely high explosion race of
2,000 feet per second is itself set off
by two blasting caps and an electric
firing device the shattering force of
the numerous medium velocity charges
rips the boulders asunder as soon as the
fragments and dust settles the engineers
will begin loading the crushed rock and
setting up for another blast in early
March work in the quarry was underway
both day and night
on 1 November 1965 the first bulldozer
moved into this area near Fond Ron and
began leveling the dry cactus dotted
earth four months later in early March a
modern jet airfield is nearing
operational state affairs thanks largely
to a new surfacing material known as a M
to the all aluminum material which is
fast replacing the familiar PSP runways
of world war ii and korean vintage comes
in 12 by 2 and 6 by 2 foot lengths the
extruded aluminum sections with a
cellular interior structure can be
rapidly interlocked to form a landing
field that will support the largest
transport plane
the work is firm wrong is being
performed by a US army engineer
battalion by more than 350 Vietnamese
laborers and by some 150 employees of a
u.s. construction firm ordered nearby at
the same time construction is underway
on other facilities needed to support
operations on a modern jet airfield here
a crane is used to unload pump pipes and
other plumbing equipment in the fuel
storage area when this activity was
filmed on March 4th and 5th large tank
for storing jet fuels were being started
and completed daily the front long
airfield located some 100 kilometers
northeast of Saigon and about 40
kilometers southwest of Cam Ranh Bay
will be the 6th jet installation in
South Vietnam its construction literally
involved moving around more than 1 and
1/3 million cubic yards of Earth RonRon
became operational in mid-march when a
tactical fighter squadron of f4 phantoms
arrived here from Holloman Air Force
Base New Mexico within eight months
another 10,000 foot runway in concrete
will be added greatly increasing the
field capacity
a competition who bridge the Rhine River
gets underway on 13 March nearly Heim
Germany between two battalions of the
24th Engineer drove the first half of
the contest involved assembling the
rafts and getting them into the water
the second phase started as the engineer
unit the 79th battalion and the 290
third Battalion began connecting the
floating bridge units to span the river
us and allied officers observe as the
contest progresses
82 floats were used in the construction
of each bridge which was twelve hundred
and twenty feet long with an overall
width of forty four feet and a travel
way of thirteen and a half feet the 79th
battalion won the contest completing its
span in just under four hours
His Royal Highness the Prince of
Luxembourg is taken to a military sports
competition based at the Heron burg
Kaserne in d'caché Luxembourg it is the
fifth time the International Council of
military force system has held its
meeting in this country posters for the
competition on 20 February are seen
everywhere and Iker the day's race comes
in the midst of formalities and festive
events running from the 17th to the 22nd
of February the military athletes of 10
participating nations line up before the
day's program begins three lieutenants
represent the United States in this
competition only military men on active
duty may compete with the firing of a
starting gun the field is alive with
movement moments later the men reached
the foot of a hill and begin their climb
on the run
their feet dig at the steep trail as
they fight to keep their place then the
trail becomes the flight of set these
races are planned to follow the
tradition of the military foot races of
the soldiers of ancient Athens strength
and staying power are tested to the
limit in this race El Ghazi of Morocco
streak home first by now the contestants
are well separated the two top spots are
won by Moroccan third place goes to a
Spanish contestant the military need is
considered successful in furthering the
sport itself in developing the character
of the contestant and in mutual
understanding all the participating
nations
in the Alpine and Scandinavian countries
skiing is one of the most important
military skills the soldier can master
here in the avi snow sports center and
beautiful huh milena Finland Xena's past
olympic winter glories the council
international do sports military sysm
held its 11th annual winter ski military
championship eight nations participated
in the Ski Championships this year and
the United States of America was
represented by its biathlon Ski Team
from Fort Richardson Alaska headed by
captain
Cleo Parker jr. and the American Alpine
Ski Team drawn mostly from the United
States Army in Europe headed by its
skiing coach lieutenant Rick Harvard one
minute past 9 on 10 March the first
contestant an American starts the
military cross-country race he is
followed by an Italian contestant the
starting interval is one minute at 9:17
contestant 17 an American moves out the
course is tough even for these military
scale
number 17 reaches the firing point in
the excitement and tension a vital
detail is almost overlooked in the race
against time
hazardous terms like this must be
precisely judged here number 23 from
America handles himself successfully at
this point what other contestants
following him have a harder time of it
the finish line is reached in this
closely contested international military
event
a man who has played a major role in the
promotion of these military sports
Brigadier General Royal Hatch US Air
Force president of fizzles
is interviewed by Lieutenant frensky
says of course has a an Academy which is
devoted to research at developing the
best method and perhaps passing it on to
some of the countries that are not as
fortunate as we are it is proved
successful in the study of boxing we
have had a clinic and develop ideas
which may make the sport survive a
little better we put out a magazine in
which some of the results of the system
Academy are printed for technicians as
well as for laymen on 13 March the
military patrol races held first up
American team - borrows a Norwegian
contestant to replace an ill member this
event features four-man team performing
cross-country skiing and marksmanship
the leadoff team crosses a snow-covered
bridge that is part of the course
meanwhile other teams continue to depart
from a star climb team fixes American an
Italian team moves swiftly along the
trail a French team tries to gain on
them the first team reaches a firing
point well aware that their marksmanship
is a vital part of the score eight
countries are competing in this festive
endurance and skill at the finish line
the time of the team's is recorded later
it will be coordinated with a
marksmanship record you'll determine the
winners of the event Colonel Robert Mont
Ando Director of Special Services at the
agent and general's office in Washington
was the senior American delegate to this
year's system skiing competition here at
Colonel Manton doe will present a plaque
of appreciation to general Hahnel US
commanding general of the armored
Brigade here at home Elena who acted as
our host for this 11th annual sysm ski
competition Colonel Martin doe general
hennala on behalf of the United States
Armed Forces it is my pleasure to
present this little silver tray to you
it is given as a token of friendship and
in sincere appreciation of the many fine
arrangements that you have made and for
the many courtesies that you have shown
the United States team thank you very
much thank you very much for your
confidence I and I hope that your team
is enjoying its being here in Finland it
is you're in thank you very much
Oh